the White House says President Trump
will insist on quote concrete verifiable
actions from North Korea's leader before
the two sit down face to face while the
date of the meeting is yet to be
determined mr. Trump tweeted last night
a deal with North Korea is very much in
the making adding quote it will be a
very good one for the world
Erol Barnett is at the White House with
more aryl good morning good morning the
White House yesterday said the u.s.
position on North Korea has not changed
insisting that it made zero concessions
in having president Trump agreed to meet
with the north korean leader kim
jeong-hoon press secretary Sarah
Saunders said the US can have these
discussions now from a position of
strength the president is getting
exactly what he wants press secretary
Sanders said a meeting between President
Trump and North Korean leader Kim
jong-un would be more than just a
photo-op facing criticism it gives the
dictator equal footing on the world
stage the president will not have the
meeting without seeing concrete steps
and concrete actions take place by North
Korea president Trump learned of the
face-to-face offer from South Korea's
national security adviser who had been
at the White House to brief
administration officials on his own
recent visit with kim jeong-hoon
almost immediately after hearing of
kim's invitation
president Trump accepted stepping into
the press briefing room to tease
reporters about the pending announcement
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson who is
traveling through Africa said he was
surprised by the change in North Korea's
posture but not by mr. Trump's decision
to agree to a sit-down
before about his willingness to me with
but the president did surprise his own
national security team by quickly
deciding the time was ripe based on a
pledge by the North Korean leader to
hold off on testing his nuclear and
missile program you know it's very
unlikely he'll ever give him up unless
some really sweet deal comes forward but
it's also unlikely he'll ever ever use
them because that would be regime
suicide Admiral sandy Winnefeld served
as the vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff in the Obama administration he
says that Trump administration's
pressure helped bring North Korea to the
table it's going to be a very
interesting play to see how the two
sides manipulate each other in advance
of the negotiations and how they conduct
themselves during the negotiations and
indeed officials from both sides now
need to overcome the logistical details
of getting both leaders into the same
room meanwhile President Trump will make
a quick trip to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
tonight to defend Ric's okones effort to
win a congressional seat there that
President Trump won by 20 points Alex
Errol Barnett at the White House thanks
Errol